- [Instructor] The function F is defined
over the real numbers.
This table gives select values of F.
We have our table here.
For these X values, it gives
the corresponding F of X.
What is a reasonable estimate
for the limit of F of X
as X approaches one from the left?
So pause this video
and see if you can figure
it out on your own.
Alright, now let's work
through this together.
So the first thing that is
really important to realize
is when you see this X approaches one
and you see this little
negative superscript here,
this does not mean
approaching negative one,
so this does not mean negative one.
Sometimes your brain just sees a one
and that little negative sign there,
and you're like oh,
this must be a weird way
of writing negative one,
or you don't even think about it,
but it's not saying that.
It's saying, this is saying,
let me put a little arrow here,
this is the limit of F of X
as X approaches one from the left,
from the left.
So from the left, how do we know that?
Well that's what that
little negative tells us.
It tells us we're approaching one
from values less than one.
If we were approaching one from the right,
from values greater than one,
that would be a positive
sign right over there.
So let's think about it.
We want the limit as X
approaches one from the left,
and lucky for us on this table,
we have some values of X
approaching one from the left.
0.9, which is already pretty close to one,
then we get even closer
to one from the left.
Notice, these are all less than one,
but they're getting
closer and closer to one.
And so what we really wanna look at
is what does F of X approach
as X is getting closer and closer to one,
from the left, from the left.
And a key realization here is,
if we're thinking about general limits,
not just from one direction,
then we might wanna look at
from the left and from the right,
but they're asking us only from the left,
so we should only be
looking at these values
right over here.
In fact, we shouldn't even
let the value of F of X
at X equal one confuse us.
Sometimes and oftentimes,
the limit is approaching a different value
than the value of the
function at that point.
So let's look at this.
At 0.9, F of X is 2.5.
When we get even closer
to one from the left,
we go to 2.1.
When we get even closer
to one from the left,
we're getting even closer to two.
So a reasonable estimate for
the limit as X approaches one
from the left of F of X,
it looks like F of X right over here
is approaching two.
We don't know for sure,
that's why they're saying,
what is a reasonable estimate.
It might be approaching 2.01
or it might be approaching 1.999.
On Khan Academy these will often be
multiple choice questions,
so you have to pick the
most reasonable one,
it would not be fair if they
gave a 1.999 as a choice
and 2.01,
but if you were saying,
hey, maybe this was
approaching a whole number,
then two could be a reasonable
estimate right over here.
Although it doesn't have to be two,
it could be 2.01258,
it might be what it is
actually approaching.
So let's try another example here.
Here it does look like
there's a reasonable estimate
for the limit as we approach
this value from the left.
So now, it says the function F
is defined over the real numbers.
This table gives select values of F,
similar to the last question.
What is a reasonable
estimate for the limit
as X approaches negative
two from the left?
So this is confusing.
You see these two negative signs.
This first negative sign tells us
we're approaching negative two.
We wanna say, what happens
we're approaching negative two,
and we're gonna approach
once again from the left.
So lucky for us, they have values of X
that are approaching
negative two from the left,
so this is X approaches
so that is happening right over here.
So that's these values.
So notice, this is negative 2.05,
then we get even closer, negative 2.01,
then we get even closer, negative 2.002,
and these are from the left
because these are values
less than negative two,
but they're getting closer
and closer to negative two.
And so let's see,
when we're a little bit
further, F of X is negative 20,
we get a little bit
closer, it's negative 100,
we get even a little bit
closer, it goes to negative 500.
So it would be reasonable,
and we don't know for sure,
this is just giving us a few sample points
for this function,
but if we follow this trend,
as we get closer and
closer to negative two,
without getting there,
it looks like this is getting unbounded.
It looks like it's becoming
infinitely negative.
And so technically, it looks like this is,
I would write this is unbounded,
and so if this was a
multiple choice question,
technically you would say the limit
as X approaches negative two
from the left does not exist,
does not exist.
If someone asked the other question,
if they said, what is the limit
as X approaches negative two
from the right of F of X,
well then you would say,
alright, well here are values
approaching negative two
from the right,
so this is X approaching
negative two from the right,
right over here.
And remember, when you're
looking at a limit,
sometimes it might be distracting
to look at the actual value
of the function at that point,
so we wanna think about what is the value
of the function approaching,
as your X is approaching that value,
as X is approaching, in
this case, negative two,
from the right.
So as we're getting closer and closer
to negative two from values
larger than negative two,
it looks like F of X is
getting closer and closer
to negative four,
which is F of negative two,
but that actually seems
like a reasonable estimate.
Once again, we don't
know absolutely for sure,
just by sampling some points,
but this would be a reasonable estimate.
And in general, if you are
approaching different values
from the left than from the right,
then you would say, a that point,
the limit of your function does not exist,
and we have seen that in other videos.